[Música]
el grupo de mercenarios rusos Wagner
asegura estar a un kilómetro del centro
de bacmut el ejército ucraniano resiste
en el oeste de la ciudad con el objetivo
declarado de ganar tiempo y desgastar
las tropas rusas a la espera de poder
lanzar una contraofensiva
Estados Unidos desmiente las palabras de
Irán sobre un supuesto acuerdo
preliminar de intercambio de prisioneros
entre ambos países Washington aseguró
que se trata de una invención de Teherán
que solo añade dolor a las familias de
los estadounidenses detenidos en la
República islámica
el ejército de Israel mató a tres
palestinos en cisjordania ocupada Ya son
80 los palestinos asesinados en 2023 el
grupo armado brigadas de los mártires de
Alexa aseguró que los muertos eran sus
militantes y el Primer Ministro Benjamín
netanyahu felicitó a sus tropas
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
más deu y es para mí un gusto
acompañarles abrimos esta edición
informativa en Ucrania porque uno de los
focos de la guerra continúa siendo
bacmut por un lado el grupo de
mercenarios rusos Wagner reitera que se
acerca cada vez más al centro de la
ciudad por otro lado el ejército
ucraniano asegura que resiste en el
flanco occidental para ganar tiempo
acumular reservistas y armamento y
desgastar a las tropas de Moscú mientras
se prepara para poder lanzar la
contraofensiva la batalla de bakmuth
recordemos dura desde agosto es una de
las más largas y mortales de esta guerra
de hecho kiev reportó que 221 soldados
prorrusos murieron en estos combates y
el Ministerio de defensa de Rusia habla
de 210 combatientes ucranianos caídos
endodo
ruinas hasta donde alcanza la vista es
todo lo que queda debajo una ciudad
industrial de 70.000 habitantes antes de
la guerra desde este verano Ruso y
ucranianos luchan encarnizadamente por
su control las fuerzas de kiev afirman
haber matado herido a más de 500
soldados enemigos en la zona en las
últimas 24 horas la batalla debajo mutes
también una batalla de comunicación el
grupo paramilitar ruso Wagner en primera
línea de los combates Afirma estar más
cerca que nunca del centro de la ciudad
el edificio de cinco plantas a la
derecha de donde sale el humo es el
centro administrativo de la ciudad
estamos a 1,2 kilómetros de ese edificio
Aunque la importancia estratégica debajo
Es cuestionable según los expertos
militares el Ministerio de defensa
ucraniano quiere mantener el control
sobre la ciudad con la estrategia de
concentrar los esfuerzos rusos en una
parte específica del frente es necesario
ganar tiempo para acumular reservas y
lanzar una contraofensiva en la
primavera que está por llegar Aunque
bajo desde el centro de atención la
guerra también continúa en el sur de
Ucrania este sábado en gerson un ataque
ruso mató a tres personas e hirió a
otras dos en Francia a pesar de las
siete jornadas de movilizaciones masivas
El senado aprobó la reforma del sistema
de pensiones del gobierno de Manuel
macron recordemos que el punto del texto
que genera más oposición entre la
sociedad francesa es el que aumenta los
años de trabajo necesarios para
retirarse con la pensión completa la
edad de jubilación pasaría de 62 a 64
años ahora la legislación volverá a
tramitarse en la asamblea nacional donde
la oposición teme que El Ejecutivo
utilice el polémico artículo
constitucional
49.3 que a la práctica le permitiría
aprobar el texto sin debatirlo
recordemos que macron descartó una
reunión con los sindicatos que ya
prueben nuevas movilizaciones
aprobado en el senado la reforma
pensional de macrón que eleva la edad de
jubilación de los 62 a los 64 años
195 miembros del senado votaron a favor
del texto mientras 112 votaron en contra
la primera ministra Elizabeth a través
de su cuenta de Twitter aplaudió la
votación tras cientos de horas de debate
el senado adoptó el texto de la Reforma
de las pensiones un paso decisivo para
llevar a cabo una reforma que
garantizará el futuro de nuestro sistema
de pensiones totalmente comprometida
para que el texto sea adoptado
definitivamente en los próximos días
pero al texto le faltan varios pasos en
el legislativo un comité conjunto de
legisladores del senado y de la asamblea
nacional discutirán el proyecto
posiblemente el miércoles si el comité
llega a un consenso el jueves se llevará
a cabo una votación final en ambas
cámaras pero el proyecto no lo tiene tan
fácil Ya que en la asamblea nacional el
partido macron necesita votos de los
aliados para obtener la mayoría de no
llegar a este gran consenso el
presidente puede aprobar el texto sin
este órgano a través de un controvertido
procedimiento llamado 49.3 las marchas
en contra del proyecto apenas lograron
convocar este sábado unas 368.000
personas un número inferior a las
anteriores cuando salieron a las calles
un millón de personas los sindicatos
planean mantener la presión el 63% de
los ciudadanos se opone al plan de
macron según las encuestas y solo una
pequeña mayoría apoya a las acciones de
huelga
en otras noticias manifestantes de
azerbaiyán bloquean desde hace tres
meses la única carretera que conecta el
nagorno carabach con Armenia lo que ha
provocado escasez de alimentos y
medicinas en esta región disputada entre
Armenia y azerbaiyán recordemos que
cerca de 120.000 armenios viven en el
nagorno caravag dentro de un territorio
reconocido internacionalmente como
azerbaiyán Según amnistía internacional
la situación humanitaria Es catastrófica
y reporteros Sin fronteras pide
azerbaiyán y a las fuerzas rusas en
misión de paz que dejen pasar a los
periodistas
Esta es la única carretera que une la
región de nagorno caravag con Armenia
desde hace tres meses el corredor de la
chin está bloqueado por un grupo de
manifestantes aceríes afirman estar aquí
para protestar contra la minería ilegal
en el enclave poblado en su mayoría por
personas de origen armenio la versión de
erevan es bien distinta estos
manifestantes estarían apoyados por las
autoridades aceríes que de este modo
pondrían en marcha indirectamente una
operación de limpieza étnica el bloqueo
ha provocado importantes carencias en
nagorno
carabaject qué podemos hacer al respecto
por supuesto es difícil no tenemos gas y
se producen cortes de Electricidad como
regularidad los ancianos conseguimos
sobrevivir pero lo siento por nuestros
hijos
durante la Guerra de otoño de 2020
azerbaiyán tomó el control de varios
territorios armenios entre ellos varios
alrededor de nagorno caravag
un negocio entonces un alto el fuego y
se desplegaron tropas rusas en la zona
el mes pasado el tribunal Internacional
de Justicia ordenó a bakú que
garantizará la libre circulación de
bienes y personas a través del corredor
la interrupción del tráfico en el
corredor de la chin impidió que las
personas de origen armenio
hospitalizadas
fueran trasladadas a centros médicos de
Armenia para recibir tratamiento de
urgencia
las pruebas también demuestran que hubo
obstáculos a la importación de productos
de primera necesidad anagorno carabaj lo
que provocó escasez de alimentos
medicinas y otros suministros médicos
vitales
sin embargo las cif rechazó la petición
de Armenia de ordenar azerbaiyán que
dejara de organizar manifestaciones y
permitiera el flujo de gas natural al
enclave por su parte las autoridades de
bakú niegan que exista un bloqueo total
en el corredor de la China y que haya
una crisis humanitaria en la región
cambiamos de tema porque en Estados
Unidos un alto cargo de la Casa Blanca
desmintió las afirmaciones del ministro
de relaciones exteriores de Irán sobre
un supuesto acuerdo preliminar de
intercambio de prisioneros entre ambos
países en una entrevista con la
televisión Estatal el diplomático iraní
aseguró que el presunto pacto tendría un
carácter humanitario
con respecto al intercambio de
prisioneros actuales entre Irán y
Estados Unidos Hemos llegado a un
acuerdo en los últimos días
si todo va bien del lado estadounidense
creo que seremos testigos de un
intercambio de prisioneros en un futuro
cercano
vemos esto como un caso totalmente
humanitario
y en Israel el Primer Ministro Benjamín
netanyahu felicitó al ejército por haber
matado a tres palestinos que
presuntamente habrían atacado un puesto
de control en cisjordania ocupada desde
principios de este año 2023 y han muerto
80 palestinos en incursiones del
ejército israelí más detalles con Luis
Muñoz
en este punto han muerto tres palestinos
el ejército israelí disparó contra ellos
y detuvo un cuarto aseguran que iban
armados el Primer Ministro Benjamín
netanyahu se alegró por estas muertes me
gustaría felicitar a los combatientes de
golán y que eliminaron a tres
terroristas en samaria como todos
podemos ver nuestras fuerzas están
operando las 24 horas del día contra
aquellos que buscan matarnos el
principio es simple cualquiera que
intente hacernos daño o nos hace daño
pagará el precio el suceso fue cerca de
naplusa en el norte de cisjordania una
zona en disputa donde Palestina quiere
construir su estado
los jóvenes muertos pertenecían a la
brigada de Mártires de alaxa una rama
armada del partido fata del presidente
de la autoridad Palestina mahamutaás las
familias quieren despedirse de sus hijos
Entonces si ellos tienen a nuestros
hijos los queremos No pedimos nada más
queremos que nuestros hijos estén aquí
que los podamos enterrar Y poder volver
a verlos
desde principios de año 80 palestinos
han sido asesinados en operativos
israelíes en 2022 fueron cerca de 150 en
el año más letal desde 2004
las incursiones de Israel son cada vez
más frecuentes en un endurecimiento del
gobierno más a la extrema derecha en 55
años un conflicto sin resolver desde que
en 1967 Israel invadiese cisjordania la
franja de gaza y el este de Jerusalén en
la guerra de medio oriente
en túnez La retórica racista y
antimigración del presidente caix
propaga y normaliza el discurso del odio
en todo el país cientos de personas
migrantes procedentes de África
subsahariana huyen de túnez para escapar
de la violencia una violencia que
también afecta a los tunecinos
afrodescendientes que temen por su
seguridad en su propio país
para nebras de 26 años febrero ha
marcado un giro para los tunecinos
afrodescendientes acaba de graduarse de
la universidad y trabaja como camarera
cree que La retórica anti inmigrante del
presidente
ha dado luz verde al racismo
hay gente que me preguntaba qué hacía yo
aquí todavía
faltando gente algunos me pararon en
medio de la calle y me dijeron que me
fuera que me fuera
el mes pasado lanzó una campaña contra
los inmigrantes subsaharianos en túnez
afirmó que estaban detrás de la mayor
parte de la delincuencia del país y que
existía un complot criminal para cambiar
la demografía de túnez los tunecinos
afrodescendientes son Realmente víctimas
colaterales del discurso del presidente
porque el discurso no iba dirigido a la
piel negra estaba dirigido a los
inmigrantes Pero obviamente son Víctimas
colaterales de este discurso los
comentarios han desencadenado una oleada
de ataques y desalojos cientos de
africanos occidentales incluso han
regresado a su país de origen por miedo
a ser objeto de ataques sadia ha ayudado
a cubrir las necesidades de los más
vulnerables pero también le preocupa que
los tunecinos afrodescendientes sean los
siguientes
somos una población visible y
estigmatizada hoy el miedo Es que seamos
el objetivo porque el primer paso son
los subsaharianos el miedo Es que el
segundo paso sea los tunecinos
afrodescendientes
[Música]
Los tunecinos afrodescendientes
representan entre el 10 y el 15% de los
12 millones de habitantes del país el
presidente ha rechazado las acusaciones
de que está avivando el racismo
afirmando que sus comentarios fueron mal
interpretados por sus oponentes y
cerramos en la capital china donde
avanza la sesión plenaria de la asamblea
popular nacional que este domingo nombró
nuevos viceministros y consejeros de
estado la sorpresa fue la ratificación
de gigan como jefe del Banco Central
dado que allí no es de los aliados más
cercanos del presidente y secretario
general del partido comunista
nuestro corresponsal en Beijing habría
fonsillas nos amplía
ha sido una sorpresa en un evento donde
siempre escasean nadie esperaba que la
asamblea nacional popular nombrara hoy
de nuevo a gigan al frente del Banco
Central de China primero porque en el
congreso del partido de octubre dejó de
formar parte del comité central segundo
porque ha alcanzado ya la edad oficiosa
de jubilación y tercero porque no forma
parte del núcleo duro de fieles del
presidente sizeping y de hecho va a
contrapelo en el pasaje de la alta
política china tiene una pasta
experiencia internacional y de hecho
vivió más de 10 años en Estados Unidos
primero estudiando el doctorado de
economía y después ejerciendo de
profesor en la prestigiosa universidad
de Illinois es por tanto una de las más
rutilantes tortugas marinas que es como
se conoce aquí en China a los que
regresan después de haber estudiado
fuera G es un firme defensor de las
reformas del mercado y evita las grandes
inversiones En infraestructuras para
patear las crisis en su hoja de
servicios a éxitos como haber mantenido
la inflación el año pasado en un 2%
cuando el resto del mundo y
especialmente occidente batía Records de
los últimos 40 años su reelección se
entiende Como una apuesta segura en unos
momentos en los que la economía china no
está para experimentos
llegamos así al final de esta emisión
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con más en France 24 y Frank 24.com
[Música]